did you over promise to the american
public what you could achieve in your
first year in office do you need to be
more realistic and scale down these
priorities why are you trying so hard
in your first year to pull the country
so far to the left
white house reporters getting their
first chance in months to question
president biden on the eve of his first
year in office
so did they deliver fox news contributor
joe koncha joins us now joe that's the
question did they deliver
um
i think there were some pointed
questions todd carly but i found the
questions overall to be a bit
disappointing lots of missed
opportunities
not one question during that two-hour
press conference yesterday about violent
crimes skyrocketing across america we've
talked about it before 16 cities setting
homicide records in 2021 it's not just
in cities it's spilling over into
suburbs you play the clips every day of
these senseless murders that are going
on many violent criminals released on
bail only to go out and commit more
crimes like we saw waukesha wisconsin
where grandmothers and children were run
over
so i thought that was a big missed
opportunity because crime is something
that the american people really feel and
i get that russia is a very big deal but
a little bit too much russia for for my
taste and not enough on domestic issues
like crime which will be a top two issue
in the 2022 midterms not one question
also and we talked about this yesterday
about the fentanyl crisis uh that is the
leading cause of death for those in this
country between 18 and 49 not one
question of why the president refuses to
visit or address the border crisis that
is a catastrophe
so as we edit head into 2022 i guess
we're in it now or going more into 2022
the criticism is polite of mr biden
compared to his predecessor but there
were some sharp edges i saw on cnn
yesterday for example when van jones
formerly of the obama biden
administration said on cnn last night he
called the press conference foggy and
meandering and also compared him to
ronald reagan at the end of his
presidency we all know that reagan was
diagnosed not too long after with
alzheimer's so
some criticism certainly not the vitriol
like we saw with donald trump but at the
same time again that press conference
yesterday i liked some of the questions
but for two hours boy we could have
covered a lot more grand right and no
questions on education either joe when
that decided the virginia election as
well i thought that one of the most
unique moments of the press conference
was when president biden got mad at a
reporter for asking about his georgia
speech on voting rights listen to this
yeah you dispute the characterization
that you called folks who would oppose
those voting bills um as being bull
connor or george wallace but you said
that they would be sort of in the same
camp no i didn't say that look what i
said go back and read what i said
and tell me
yeah so i am going to read what he said
he said do you want to be on the side of
dr king or george wallace do you want to
be on the side of john lewis or bull
connor so what do you make of the
president uh denying
um
this what he said instead of owning up
to it
i i thought the reporter in that
situation could have had that quote
ready right if he he paraphrased what
the president said and if he was ready
with like okay sir let me read back my
words to you just as you just did carly
and for the president to react so
angrily regardless uh that's not mr
unity that we're seeing up there anymore
that's get off my lawn joe biden and
that didn't play well at all in that
situation overall i thought the press
conference was a net negative for this
president i don't see a vision for 2022
he's going to continue doing the same
things the same messaging and that did
not work in 2021 when your approval
rating in quinnipiac is only 33 percent
one out of three americans supporting
this president right now
are we going to see one of these press
conferences again anytime soon joe no
we're not going to see one this one it
took 300 days between formal press
conferences that's enough to deliver a
baby to full term right plus a month to
take afterwards to enjoy the moment so
yeah you're not going to see one
probably i think at least until the
summer not in this sort of setting
certainly for not that period of time
but carly i heard before you're not a
good driver you're from jersey i mean i
know how could you not be in a good
jersey around here just for self
surviving
and questions on if president biden was
a good
driver in the driver's seat yesterday
during that press conference joe thank
you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now